Brian Kilmeade is going to be a much
more based a version of Tucker Carlson
you know everyone thinks Brian Kilmeade
is uh is the new Tucker yeah that's what
I keep here and the kids say on
twitter.com it's actually I I guess it
doesn't work it's not funny because no
one knows who Brian Kilmeade is but
right yeah he's not talking about Jesse
Waters was the number two show right
yeah I mean why don't they put Jesse in
that slot yeah
yeah does anybody have a reason I don't
know I couldn't tell you why they should
or shouldn't they should uh just not put
anyone in that slot and just put dead
air exactly it just and now a moment of
silence for the next hour for the next
hour and in memory of Tucker Carlson and
then it just shows black and white
pictures of him with sad piano music
playing like Tucker Carlson year of
birth to 2023 so that that's what
they're gonna do to convince the
audience like that he's dead don't
follow him anywhere
we never said he was dead you can't take
us to court but they just mislead the
audience into thinking he's dead so that
they can effectively cancel him